[Applause]
welcome back
here go ahead it's all right it's all
right
um do you get that just when you enter
Target like you go like people are just
like wow
so wait do you get into Christmas oh I
love love Christmas it is my favorite
holiday me too I love it and we usually
spend Christmas in Hawaii which is kind
of different because it is not very
snowy not very snowy but nice
um it's where Brock is from yeah that's
where his family is and because it's so
far away it's really the time we get to
spend with them so it's become a
tradition I love Hawaii I do love it I
mean that was half the reason why I said
yes
from Hawaii yeah we got lucky there so
wait before the show we asked our our
rad mom viewers if they had any question
for Mrs Obama so let's do one of those
right now so Alicia from Minneapolis
asks before we had kids my husband and I
agreed to share the work
oh sorry so to share the work of
parenting 50 50. oh see we all laughed
you could barely even get that out like
silly silly men both both of us have
careers let me tell you it's 70 30 on a
good day I think you're winning
um I realize this man will probably
never change which is frustrating
because he's truly a good dad and
husband what is your advice on how to
manage my feelings about this I feel
like we should just send her Elsa
singing Let It Go
[Applause]
it's like you know what but that's great
you know that's great advice we have all
been through it that whole 50 50 I write
in the book The presenting partner it
doesn't exist and it's not realistic
yeah
um what I would say is you're busier at
different times too exactly I mean has
it been 50 50 in moments no has it been
50 50 for me over 30 years yes it
balances oh I like that yeah so what my
advice would be make sure you're taking
care of yourself you know because that's
the thing that we do sometimes we take
on more because we feel guilty when we
go work out or when we go to the
hairdresser and so it and and we also
don't trust him with our kids will they
arrive when they act without a broken
phone tax so we have to like you said
Let It Go my advice when I stopped
resenting my husband for that yeah was
when I started prioritizing myself and I
didn't wait for him so the help I
learned didn't have to come from him but
I needed it so I relied on my mom and my
girlfriends in a broader community of
people to give me that break so that I'm
not so mad at him all the time I think
that that's good too though as well
because a village is raising my kids
with me you know whether it's Grandma
whether it's my you know sister whether
it's my nanny whether it's my people
around me my friends like I think my
Village has gotten out of that habit
that notion we're making moms feel like
they have to do it all and it was never
like that I mean we're really the first
generation of the nuclear family it's
just like me my husband and my kids or
my partner my kids that was never the
case I was raised in community I was
raised with a great aunt downstairs
around the corner yeah you know you have
to rely on a community of people to make
it happen that's the way you raise good
kids and they get benefit from being
exposed to different people different
absolutely you know approaches find more
Independence exactly so don't and try to
do it on your own you know do it with
him get his 30 and get the other 50 from
other people and then listen to Let It
Go in your head
called the light we carry so you've
referred to your new book as a toolbox
of sorts which the only place I've ever
heard this is either at my kids school
it's a great school my kids go to or in
therapy because it's something for you
because it's something for your topics
to learn it's like obviously I haven't
learned this lesson because it keeps
hitting me in the face like what does it
mean for you like a toolbox what does
that mean for me it's just the habits
and practices that I've accumulated over
the course of my 58 years of life that
get me through uncertainty and tough
times which we have all been going
through
um and I get asked a lot as the former
first lady is somebody who's out there
as a public figure as I assure you are
especially from young people how do I
find my voice you know how do I uh
because sometimes you're afraid to say
something exactly yeah exactly people
want to know how do you find a good
partner what how do I parent
um all this book is my offering but I
also want this to be this book to lead
to a conversation of other mothers women
people sharing how they get through
because uncertainty is baked Into The
Human Experience and I think too much
time is spent trying not to feel anxious
or feel uncertain filter yourself like
to filter yourself when the truth is you
got to just lean into the fact that
that's part of life
how do we figure out how to manage it
yeah you know how do we get through
without falling apart I love what you
just said too because I feel like it's
kind of a dedication the book that
ignited the light in you right I feel
like that's what you're trying to do for
others is ignite their life yeah and
everybody has that light yeah and I
think in times like this where we feel
divided and the messaging out there is
negative we start to think
there's no light out there but I my
experience is the former first lady
living in this country is everybody's
got that light you know and over time we
it's either fueled especially when we're
kids it's fueled by love and support and
investment or it can be slowly snuffed
out by hatred and bigotry and laughing
they just get beaten down but the light
is there it's in all of us I feel like
too it's about small things because I
feel like the world can be overwhelming
even like this show we have such a stage
to help so many people but it can be
overwhelming there's so much need
there's so many people doing amazing
things but it can get overwhelming
especially watching the news can be very
um just sold it should be paralyzed yeah
it's just Soul crushing and you're like
you kind of feel hopeless but I feel
like it's the small things I feel like
you touch on this too it's one of the
chapters it's called The Power of small
um and the smaller ripples I give that
advice to a lot of young kids who feel
overwhelmed by the bigness of the
problems we're facing and they're facing
yeah what I've learned to do is to
control what I can and throughout the
stages in my life that power and control
has has varied you know what I was able
to control at 15 is very different from
what I can control as the first lady of
the United States but what I could do
was what I had control over and
sometimes that helps uh us to prevent
from making great the enemy of the good
sometimes if we feel like we can't fix
everything then we feel like we
shouldn't do anything at all and I don't
want young people to get burnt out
especially as they're thinking about big
problems like climate change yeah
criminal justice and racism and global
economy it's that's what I'm saying it
could be over you may be fine to focus
you're 15. you know if you're 15 your
focus should be school you know do your
homework that's what you can control you
know don't bite off so much before you
have the ability to really handle it so
um there's a whole chapter on that
that's an important tool of mine even in
in my position I have I stay hopeful
because I look at the thing right in
front of me that I can actually do you
know we can't fix climate change if
we're not going to vote and voting is
that small thing that we all control big
thing that is a big thing that's the
power of how small it is power of the
people absolutely
so in this new book you say your girls
are in the flea market stage of life so
what is that that that's a metaphor also
for watching your adult children start
to create home for themselves yeah so we
went by their apartment Barack and I for
cocktails before dinner oh my gosh they
had made a couple of week martinis which
I was glad to know they didn't they
didn't really know how to make
Martinique like did you put alcohol in
it yeah it was it was it was bad but it
was a good effort good effort so they
had the nerve to then as we put down
drinks and be like let me get a coaster
and I was like oh all of a sudden do we
care about readings right now
yeah you care about your little four
dollar coffee table I know you know I
you didn't care about coasters in the
white house for all eight years I didn't
see you rushing to protect that antique
it's so true because I started making my
kids I take them I'm like I'm gonna show
you what toys cost because you're
unaware so I make them and I said oh
they're like we had twenty dollars just
cooking I go yeah let's go with your
twenty dollars and see what you're gonna
get oh yeah and they were so
disappointed
and I'm like welcome that's their whole
you know they're very cheap now with
their own money which oh yeah with ours
though they're not with my wallet
they're fine
so you know cobbling together an
apartment building a life creating their
own friendships watching them build
their own Community yeah it's like
better than I expected I mean I miss
having them with me but just watching
them become real people yeah in the
world and doing okay adulting adulting
and they say I can't imagine my kids
like they're six and eight and you know
you don't need to they're not ready the
world isn't ready they're not ready yeah
that's why they're with you yeah another
thing that a lot of us Mamas deal with
is making friends as an adult and I love
that you refer to this is it the kitchen
table Yeah so what is explain with the
kitchen table I love this that's cool I
call it the kitchen table because
growing up that everything happened in
the kitchen you know yeah because you
come to your kitchen table for safety
and love and security right so I called
it that but for me it's my friendship
group outside of my family I still have
my mom my my family crew but we
particularly as women women I find that
my kitchen table those are the other
people that allow stop me from being mad
at the 30 percent my husband is giving
me yeah because they're stepping up and
giving me what he cannot yeah and I want
my girls to practice developing a
kitchen table that's a tool the kitchen
table is a tool right yeah and I
experienced that as first lady I mean I
had to make new friends because I was
still a mother raising kids and rad moms
know you've got to have mother friends
in the school yeah so I had to step out
nobody was going to come up to me you
know you couldn't even get near me with
security yeah so I was like they're
probably scared they were yeah they were
probably scared so I tell the story of
the first time I set up a play date for
Sasha because I just had to find a
mother that I thought I wanted to meet I
just loved it you're doing
she is now a good friend of mine but at
first I just saw her and I was like why
don't you have little Olivia come over
and of course she was like sure and so
she later as we became friends she told
me the story of what it was like coming
to pick Olivia up after that for coming
to the White House which that you know
what what is on the other side of being
my friend well it is a social security
check it's uh you know background check
all background check it's a clear vet
before you can even come in oh my gate
um not to mention she wasn't even coming
in the house but she went and got her
hair done her nails done washed her car
she was like yeah I was like I am not
showing up messy at the White House
since the so she pulls in and I decide
outside of protocol that I'm going to
take a little Olivia down to the South
lawn would you do not leave the
residence as a principal because it sets
off all this outside security the
counter assault team goes into action oh
my God flak jackets with machine guns
dogs they start descending yeah here I
come her car is now rounded by security
I step out into the South lawn with
little Olivia and I'm like
get out but she had been explicitly told
under no
circumstances now are you too Lee get
out of your car this woman is about to
be okay get out and she's like
so she slowly gets out to carefully and
we have a great chat she played it all
off I didn't know any of this so I'm
retelling her story oh this is a nice
woman and she is now one of my best
friends Olivia is like a daughter to me
you know lo and behold a new Daisy
popped up and it is a beautiful thing
and if I hadn't taken the risk to extend
myself and to reach out to a stranger
you know yeah and make a friend she
wouldn't be in my life and so if I can
make new friends
anybody all right because there's people
ready
oh my God we need another break but
first Mrs Obama brought an early
Christmas gift for everyone here you are
all going on with a copy of her new book
The Light weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]